building a startup is a journey you have
limited resources and have to manage the
delicate balance of building quickly
while keeping costs under control
building infrastructure and internal
tools and properly managing your team's
time whether you're building a
multiplayer game or a global ecommerce
platform an important choice that every
startup needs to make is choosing the
right cloud provider
in this video we'll share why google
cloud is a great option for startups
across four primary dimensions speed
intelligence savings and partnerships
we'll meet with members of the customer
engineering team and startup success
team to show you why top startups choose
google cloud
[Music]
pillar one let's start with the first
pillar speed the ability to go from code
to production quickly is critical to
startup growth
hi i'm anthony bouchan a developer
advocate here at google cloud one of the
ways startups build faster is with
microservices and container architecture
containers as many of you likely know
are used widely across many different
sectors and are even used here heavily
at google today
google kubernetes engine or gke for
short
provides a seamless solution for
managing your containers at scale
gke provides a single place to interact
with all of your containers either
manually through a ui or
programmatically through the command
line interface
it not only helps you with that but also
manages your dns networking load
balancing and traffic management all in
a single place
managing your containers has never been
easier and our startups are surprised
every day at how easy it is to scale
manage and save even at a global level
for example if a customer needed to spin
up remote workstations to power gpu
accelerated processing for 3d imaging
they could use gke to seamlessly auto
scale the workstations up and down for
their customers needs
some startups tend to prefer more
abstracted serverless architecture does
google cloud support serverless
architecture
yes
startups need to move quickly and adjust
to rapidly changing product requirements
and user demand
serverless architecture enables this at
all levels so let's quickly dive into
these
google cloud offers a variety of
different serverless products ranging
from data management solutions to
compute and more
but with that serverless can come in
many different shapes and sizes and
should be carefully selected based on
your startup's specific requirements
what requirements you may ask
in most cases it will be chosen based on
a set of technical requirements needed
to achieve your end result
for example if containers are needed you
may choose cloud run over cloud
functions as cloudrun gives you the
ability to build and use your own
containers and still deploy quickly
i would highly suggest taking a look at
all our serverless offerings though if
you have a chance
i've found startups to use them heavily
to give the team more time to focus on
building features for their startup and
not managing their cloud infrastructure
are there any other ways google cloud
empowers startups to innovate quickly
and easily
yes
devops is something most startups
overlook initially but is an integral
part in the success of your company as
we all know engineering time is valuable
but with devops we can help direct that
attention to building and not
maintaining
google cloud offers a ton of resources
and products to help automated
deployment testing and more depending on
your startup's needs you may be fine
with connecting a single trigger
to a build and deploy new commits
while others may automate the entire
process of testing building and
deploying to production through the use
of cloud triggers cloud build and cloud
run for a seamless end-to-end deployment
by using cloud run you are able to
easily trigger new version deploys or
roll back and even split traffic for a b
testing
let's move on to the second pillar
intelligence startups need to be able to
easily aggregate data and then turn data
into real-time insights
using these real-time insights can help
your startup unlock powerful information
to improve decision making
hi i'm alison corner i'm a customer
engineer here at google if there's one
thing google is known for it's data i've
had many startups worry that google
cloud won't be able to manage the
quantity of data that they have but i've
never seen that be a limitation for any
of my customers as long as they're using
the right tools this massive ability to
scale makes it a great platform for
customers who want to turn their data
into insights to grow their business
what google cloud tools are available to
help customers manage their database at
scale
this is a very common question that
customers ask
many customers run into issues managing
databases at scale which is why they
choose to use some of our managed
database tools
customers would rather allocate time to
build their product instead of
dedicating time to manage a complex
database
fortunately we have many databases that
allow customers to save time and focus
on building their core product
we have database offerings such as cloud
sql bigquery cloud spanner firestore
bigtable etc let's look at the database
cloud spanner cloud spanner is one of
google cloud's fully managed relational
databases
it's built to manage large amounts of
data and it has massive scale
seamless replication across regions in
google cloud strong external consistency
and processes over 1 billion requests
per second at peak cloud spanner and all
of these databases i've mentioned
earlier were developed with customers in
mind they allow engineers to focus on
the product instead of managing the
tools the product runs on so they're
able to make more progress much faster
now that we understand the tools that
allow startup customers to manage their
database at scale
what tools are available to help
customers unlock insights
one tool the customers i work with
really enjoy using is bigquery
if you're familiar with bigquery it's a
serverless highly scalable and
cost-effective multi-cloud data
warehouse designed for business agility
customers use bigquery for their
analytic workloads and to glean insights
from their data
if a customer is using both bigquery and
spanner they also get to take advantage
of how seamlessly these products work
together both tools share a lot of the
same underlying infrastructure which
allows customers to execute
transactional and analytic workloads
easily and manage high throughput needs
does google cloud have tools that allow
startups to increase innovation with
machine learning
yes so google cloud does have various
offerings in the aiml space we have
tools like automl and bigquery ml to
help startups innovate faster with ai
expertise what's also really helpful to
startups is that these aiml offerings
are built in a way to allow people who
aren't ml experts to build ml models or
use pre-trained models to benefit their
business
this means that startups that otherwise
would not have been able to afford a
data engineer can create their own
models using basic sql or coding skills
this gives them a leg up and helps level
the playing field when it comes to
competing against larger companies in
their space
for example i've seen many startups
benefit from using recommendations api
to provide personalized recommendations
that suit each customer's tastes and
preferences instead of having to build
their own ml model these startups are
able to benefit from google's experience
and expertise in the area and use a
simple api to improve customer
experience startups also benefit from
using vertex ai which they can use to
train their own custom models thanks
alison for sharing all that great
insight
key aspect of startup growth is the
ability to save money when building on
or migrating to cloud-native
architecture
cloud is often the biggest expense for a
startup
and to operate efficiently they need to
optimize spending with cost management
tools
cost savings is a pillar that google
cloud excels in
hi i'm kayla gore a google customer
engineer i'll share how choosing google
cloud can help your startup save money
one of the ways google cloud helps
startups save money is providing
automatic scale up and down tools
depending on traffic and growth this
helps to reduce the risk of overpayment
for over provisioned resources for
example based on the needs of your
workloads google kubernetes engine
cluster autoscaler dynamically resizes
the number of nodes in a specific node
pool
you can auto-scale deployments based on
pod cpu utilization
and gcp also supports scaling
deployments based on custom metrics
exported from google cloud monitoring
startups are often working with a very
limited budget does google cloud provide
cost transparency or cost optimization
one of google cloud's strengths is cost
transparency google cloud offers a
comprehensive collection of free billing
and cost management tools that can
provide you with the visibility and data
you need to manage your cloud
deployments
as well as documentation and tutorials
to help you understand how much things
cost because once you understand the
cost of a tool you can put controls in
place to minimize your expenditure for
example let's take the product bigquery
to show the different ways customers
have access to cost transparency and
cost savings
customers who use bigquery can create
dashboards to view their billing data
which allows them to subsequently make
adjustments to their bigquery usage
customers can also consider streaming
audit logs to bigquery to analyze user's
patterns
bigquery billing data can be exported
into visualization tools like cloud data
studio
finally bigquery customers also have
access to bigquery flex slots flex slots
are a way to purchase bigquery analytics
capacity for short durations as little
as 60 seconds at a time
flex slots let you quickly respond to
rapid demand for analytics and prepare
for business events such as retail
holidays and app launches this can lead
to major cost savings for customers
are there any other ways startups can
save money with google cloud
yes so google cloud also offers pricing
efficiency features including things
like sustained use discounts committed
use discounts flat rate pricing per
second billing and other volume
discounting tools that allow you to
optimize charges for a given service
a startup i worked with was looking for
ways to save money so i advise them to
use the idle vm recommender which
monitors utilization metrics to identify
inactive virtual machines and persistent
disks
the customer was able to save money by
deleting idle instances from a proof of
concept that were no longer needed
thanks kayla for sharing how startups
can save money by choosing google cloud
the final pillar is partnership
this is another area where google cloud
excels in
knowing your startup will be supported
through your journey using google cloud
allows founders to know that google
cloud is committed to their success
google cloud has an entire team
dedicated to helping startups this is
called the startup success team
hi
i'm jeremy massey a startup success
manager here at google cloud
our startup success team is passionate
about helping startups thrive we're
fully dedicated to meeting founders and
their teams at whatever stage of the
startup journey they're on and providing
holistic support for our customers as
they grow could you give us an example
of how the startup success team supports
startup customers we support customers
by establishing a one-on-one
relationship with founders that come
through our google for startups cloud
program
in this program startups get access to
dedicated experts cloud credits for two
years up to a hundred thousand dollars
each year and guidance from google
engineers
all of these resources are meant to help
startups build a thriving and
sustainable business
in the google for startups cloud program
the startup success team spends time to
understand our customers unique goals
roadmap and timeline
after understanding what will have the
most impact for their business we work
with them to find the best ways to put
their google cloud credits to use
could you share a customer story and how
you helped the customer decide the best
way to use their credits for google
cloud
i recently met with the early stage
environmental science startup who's
currently planning how to build and
deploy their application on google cloud
through a few conversations our team was
able to help them develop their initial
architecture and identified the google
cloud iot core cloud pub sub and cloud
functions to be a great way for them to
use their google cloud credits
they're now able to easily and securely
connect manage and ingest data from
their globally dispersed devices
how else does the startup success team
help customers
we support customers by partnering with
our customer engineering team to hold
technical discoveries
architecture reviews and provide
interactive technical workshops
our customer engineering team recently
led an interactive session on google
cloud's ai and ml capabilities to a
group of startups currently
participating in the google cloud for
startups black founders fund
startups really value this expert
mentoring and technical training which
also allows them to upskill their own
teams
having access to these discussions must
be very helpful to startups are there
any final ways the ssm team supports
startups
we provide ongoing support and
partnerships to startups as they grow
we understand that startups have
evolving needs and we're committed to
helping founders build a sustainable and
successful business over the long term
i recently worked with a startup focused
on big data who was ready to do a full
migration from another cloud provider
and they were looking for third-party
assistance
i was able to connect them to one of the
partners in our network specializing in
migrations to ensure they had the full
support and additional expertise to
facilitate their migration
this sounds like such a great program
for startups how can startups get in
touch with a startup success manager
so if you're interested in getting
access to the startup success team and
participating in the google for startups
cloud program
please visit cloud.google.com
startup and there you'll be able to find
more information about the program
thanks jeremy for sharing your insight
there you have it we've shown you how
google cloud can be an amazing resource
for your startup on four core pillars of
speed intelligence savings and
partnerships to learn more about the
information provided in this video
please visit
cloud.google.com
startup
if you enjoyed this video please make
sure to tap the like button and
subscribe to this youtube channel thanks
for watching
[Music]